[Music]
so
at first you might find it easier if you
take
this shape this shape okay
the beginning of your inward spiral
so i'm going to come up into the
shoulders
you'll feel ah that's i'm now starting
to go over
okay so up in your shoulders and then
start okay but
like with all things once you understand
it shapes mounted
shapes not important nor structure no
posture those are all training tools
okay
so maybe boom but
[Music]
oh
so in the technique he's coming up right
and there's a certain point where uh
he's falling like you don't have to get
him up in the air
you once once you feel his his life
you go down you blend with that
lightning
boom oh there it is
oh
is going to go out home
down angle cancellation
hey